ron starts us off in houston texas this
hour
hey ron welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
man what's up
well i have a question me and my wife
for one baby step six
and uh we've we've got a high risk
investment uh that's worth about twenty
five thousand dollars right now
and we're we're getting it to the point
where it's uncomfortable
uh where we wanna sell the investment
and cash it out
and i would like to spend about half of
it on a uh
a vehicle that i've always wanted and
she's uneasy about that just
just spending that amount of money on
something that's uh you know completely
a luxury and not not necessary
uh so i was gonna see if you could weigh
in and let us know what your opinion is
on it
well i'm an expert on my opinion chris
christie can weigh in also
that's fine the the thing that i have uh
found on is if it falls under the
heading of wisdom
it generally is a small ratio
toys that are a large ratio
in your life meaning they're a high
percentage of your income or they're a
high percentage of your net worth
is a toy you shouldn't do but one of the
reasons we work
is to buy some toys and there's nothing
evil about having a toy
and so and that's what this is that's
what you're describing and you're
talking about spending twelve or
thirteen thousand dollars right
correct okay and what's your household
income
uh we made eighty thousand last year
okay and what are your other cars worth
uh my car my i've got an old pickup
truck in my wife's car they're worth
about 20 000 combined
okay well one of the rules of thumb we
use is uh you're debt free everything
but your house and we want you to be
there
the other rule of thumb we use is don't
buy things with motors or wheels
all combined that equal more than half
your annual income right
and so you're not doing that it hasn't
violated that you'd be at 32 and you
make 80. so you'd still be fine
what are you talking about buying just
curious uh a bmw
z4 coupe okay all right cool so a a
little mid-life crisis car that's fun
i like it i like it i've got one of
those i don't have that car but i like i
got a couple of mid-life crisis cars i
live in a perpetual midlife crisis
when it comes to cars that is so um
and um how much do you guys have in your
401k
uh i'm 33 years old and i've got just
over a hundred thousand
okay all right
ron are you this are you the uh spender
i am the spender she you know one of the
the reasons that we're in the position
we're in is
is because my wife is so frugal and and
she has a hard time spending money on
anything i
i have to buy her things most of the
time because she wants to spend it on
herself
yeah i would guess that just because
like we we teach all the time a lot of
times in marriage there's a saver and a
spender my
husband is the saver i am the spender so
the conversation sounds a lot in our
household like the conversation you're
having regardless of what it is and
and the situation we're in but here's
here's a couple questions i ask him
whenever he is unsure about a purchase
because i will tell you he is usually
unsure about
purchase he he gives me the classic line
that draws me crazy
let me think about it that's a title oh
a week a week later let me think about
it he's a title
six months later i'm still thinking
about i'm like oh my goodness here's
some questions
i just asked him ron what are you
worried about what fears do you have
around this
what are your concerns and i give him
him opportunity to voice those concerns
and
and sometimes they are things we can
address and talk through together
sometimes they're really valid and maybe
a blind spot i didn't see because i'm
such a spender and i'm like oh that's a
great idea
so that's what's so great about having
these conversations in your marriage
because you come to the best decision
together
but i would just say give her an
opportunity
to voice those concerns to talk through
those concerns to actually nail him down
it can't just be i don't know i'm just
scared let's look
what what are you worried about what are
what are your concerns what would what
would help you
feel better about this decision and that
type of thing and so um i think maybe
asking some of those questions giving
her a chance to answer
will allow her to feel more of a part of
the decision either way
and then you're kind of moving forward
together but i you know i just want to
encourage you if you open that door you
might be surprised at what she has to
say and it might lead to
y'all coming together on this that's a
good point because it might just let the
steam off
i might let the air out of the problem
but you know so
by ratios what i'm referring to ron and
for the sake of all our listeners as
well
i kind of ask myself when i'm dealing
with someone who's wealthy or someone
who's doing well financially you all are
doing well financially if i put my that
amount of money
in your situation in the middle of the
floor
and i burned it would it destroy my life
would it mess up my life would it set me
back five years
would it set me back a year would it
would it would it do
damage to where i mean obviously we
don't want to be that wasteful that's
silly okay but
but the point is if you if the car
caught on fire the next day and burned
to the ground and you had no insurance
would you have ruined your finances and
your future
or seriously set them back or would you
just not
notice you know like i had a guy call me
up one time that was making six hundred
thousand dollars a year and he was all
worried about buying a twenty thousand
dollar harley
and i'm like dude you could drive it off
a cliff once a month and nobody would
care i mean you know
you're gonna be okay it does it's not
gonna affect because of the ratio to his
income you see what i'm saying
so that's what you know and you're
this this would this is a big enough
ratio that you would feel it but it
wouldn't
mess your life up and so that tells me
it tells me it's a buy if i'm in your
shoes i'm buying the car okay so i got a
question for you dave on this because in
in marriage you do typically have a
saver have a spender one of the things
i've noticed and i would say matt's not
like this matt is cautious but he he
will spend money on things that you know
that he likes what about those type of
people and i don't know that ron's wife
is like this but what about those people
that
genuinely don't like spending money they
just don't and so you've got this spouse
that's going but this but we have the
money but it's okay we've got this thing
and they just they can't they hate
spending money and so it's really hard
for them to ever say yes to a decision
because they hate letting go of it how
do you help how do you help them
those savers open their hands a little
bit you know
rachel and i were talking about this a
little bit yesterday on the air with the
launch of her
know yourself know your money book
because she talks about the spender
versus the saver and she talks about the
seven tendencies and that's one of the
seven tendencies are you a saver your
spender
and the thing that she so wisely points
out is if you
both neither one of those are bad it's
not bad to be a savior
but what is unhealthy is if either one
go to the extreme
and what you're talking about is a saver
that has gone to the extreme they
cannot get joy from the handling of
money in their finances they can never
get enough
to get a sense of joy into purchasing
something uh and usually what i
prescribe for them is
uh increased generosity when you start
giving more
well it causes you to have more of a
sense of abundance
more of a sense of open hand i'm not i
don't have to have this for my security
i'm not damaging or ruining my life by
helping this person with this
thousand dollar gift or whatever it is
and when you start giving more
especially hand to
not not to vague organizations big big
buildings but to just say
this individual i'm gonna help this
single mom pay a light bill for a year
or something like that then that causes
you to
to become a little bit less freaked out
and you can move towards enjoyment of
money yourself
yeah because it also kind of gives you
permission to enjoy money right because
you're helping others yeah
so but you don't want to be too far on
either end of the spectrum it is toxic
when you do that